spring in Rich Eisen he's the host of
the Rich Eisen show conveniently named
on DirecTV the audience network and also
the NFL Network what's the schedule for
you guys on Saturday and Sunday on the
NFL Network rich we're on the air four
and a half hours before kickoff of
Falcons Saints so that's noon eastern 9
a.m. out here on the left coast and then
we'll turn right around and be at our
post usual time of 9 a.m. Eastern on
Sunday morning prior to Pittsburgh and
Jacksonville let me ask you about the we
ended last I were talking about Monday
Night Football and would you how would
Tom Brady be in that role but let me
make you the boss of ESPN and you're
gonna bring down somebody for Monday
Night Football trying to replace Jon
Gruden and you can have anybody who
would you take Peyton Manning would you
take him over Brady yeah absolutely
right for I would yes I would I would
you know I'm considering every single
person that I could it be it would be
Peyton Manning he's he's got the
greatest name recognition possible he's
got the gift of gab he's funny and would
be a huge monster splash hire and I
think he'd be terrific at it I think
he'd be great at it I just don't know if
he's gonna do it or wouldn't want to do
it right now I think most people believe
his his post-playing career route should
it involve football would be the Elway
yeah roll not not be about the analyst
role yeah and I don't know what I know
Brady has shown glimpses of a sense of
humor and some of the commercials he's
done and I brought up an interview I did
with him over the phone for ESPN the
magazine on the back page and he was
really funny self-deprecating and I'm
gonna guess he would tackle that like he
does anything else he wants to be great
at it Brady would be a curiosity for me
Farb I think would be fun how about
Favre and Randy Moss together sure yeah
I mean
anything to mix it up I I was one of
those who enjoyed Dennis Miller you know
just having somebody different in the
booth from the perspective of you know
conventional wisdom you know Cosell was
that if you think about it I know you're
very original Monday Night Football
booth I just don't know you know I think
in reality I know that there the name
names being mentioned involves one of my
guys in Kurt Warner and you know I I
don't know what his actual status is and
you know in terms of ESPN taking
somebody from the game day morning set
that might actually help two birds with
one rating stone right there
but Steve Young to me would be a great
choice I mean he's already in the
building he's already there he's already
somebody who's I think done it before
didn't he'd do one of those with boomer
few years ago one of those back-end
Monday night double headers on ESPN but
that seems to me they he's already in
out Doherty at the games and he's a
hall-of-famer who knows the game very
well and I think and can speak off the
top of his head in the manner in between
snaps that you need yeah he would be
great but trying to get that kind of new
blood in there and I agree with the I I
think Payton looks at being more of a
guy running a team than doing Monday
Night Football we're talking to Rich
Eisen from the NFL Network Blake bortles
comparing the criticism he receives to
LeBron James I thought he said look if
the Bron James has detractors then you
know obviously I am and then people are
saying he's comparing himself to LeBron
James which takes about five different
you know we've we've had more leaves
trying to connect Kevin Bacon to Cicely
Tyson you know what I mean so all right
well let me get the quote here bortles
on criticism do you have it's eaten
alright let's play it so we can put it
in context
it'll probably never stop and there's
people to think the Bron James sucks so
if that happens I'm sure there'll be a
lot of people that always think I said
yeah you know what I mean so I don't
think he's he's saying that he's King
Blake you know I mean I didn't take it
that way did you no no no I think what
he's saying is as great as LeBron is he
still has detractors so I'm always gonna
have detractors because I I'm not LeBron
James and he has people who are you know
criticizing him so my god loving fun I
you know and uh he just he just looked
terrible in his first playoff game and
just looked terrible and you know I've
never seen a team win a playoff game and
then the quarterback win a playoff game
and the narrative still is man how great
would this team be with a veteran
quarterback on it I mean that's part of
the reason what makes this game so great
in Pittsburgh if they can one-and-done
the Steelers one would think it would
have to be because bortles plays an
efficient game it's and and
interestingly enough you know when
bortles came out the guy that he was
being compared to it the combine a lot
was Roethlisberger you know guy with
size a big arm the ability to extend to
play with his legs sometimes when he's
hit the play begins as opposed to ending
and here he goes into that building for
his first road career playoff game and
you know the the defense turning been
over five times last time and then
Leonard fournette running through it was
what was the answer so this is a big
spot for him but I still think that when
it's all said and done the Alex Smith
rumors will be strong come the combine
time march/april leave ins wonder what
the new coach of the Giants whoever
that's going to be is going to do with
Eli would that be a mix so yes III
understand what Blake saying but anybody
who sits there and thinks that he's
comparing himself to LeBron is it's kind
of and he ran himself into the permanent
job there in Jacksonville oh yeah sure
if he if they win in Pittsburgh and then
they they can hold a New England did win
in New England why would you touch
anything I mean
you'd think but look I think here's
here's how the narrative to never end
and the Atlanta Falcons are a perfect
example of that all right so they lose
the Super Bowl in that fashion and then
all offseason long we talk about that
Super Bowl loss and then throughout the
entire season there we talk about the
Super Bowl loss being a hangover then
they make the playoffs and then they
crush it against the Rams then we see
the Georgia Bulldogs losing that manner
and we're still talking about how
Atlanta fans have suffered the same
thing and we will see that Super Bowl
loss replayed over and over again
throughout the game against the Eagles
and should they win that against whoever
they play in the NFC Championship game
even if they're up at the halftime of
the Super Bowl we're still talking about
it
so it's very difficult to shake a
narrative sometimes in the NFL and
Blake's learning that clearly you've won
on Kimmel soon here Rich Eisen Jimmy
Kimmel Arg very excited about that yeah
now it's coming down now how do you plan
your story you see they want to know
that they pre-interview you right okay
and then they want to know hey what do
you think who's going to be in the Super
Bowl or this is probably on the on the
eve of the Super Bowl week I'm guessing
that you'll be on with two now yet it's
the Wednesday before heading to
Minnesota
okay so then they're gonna so know yeah
so look at you you'll give a Super Bowl
prediction and then they're gonna
probably want you have any fun Super
Bowl stories I don't know here's the
thing Dan you know how it goes they get
a call and you tell stories and and you
know the the producer will will probably
laugh at all of them and you're
wondering if it's really funny or not
and then you give them about 20
different things and and only two gets
used and and you just hope you have a
good conversation no I mean yeah I know
you were on Letterman I was on Letterman
at the draft he had me on at the draft
during the lockout because Letterman was
fascinated by how the NFL is having a
draft during a lockout he just really
wanted to know all those questions
I remember thinking to myself I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that I'm gonna say
this I'm gonna say that and I got a
buddy of mine who knows Letterman very
well having worked with him for decades
it's just like just sit back and let him
drive the bus and just also be careful
that a it's cold and be he blocks out
the audience so anytime he is a laughs
you'd think it's coming from avoid and
it's just really freaky but I guess once
you've done that the rest of it is kind
of a different story yeah they would
pre-interview you on Letterman then you
would you would think like you were
waiting for the hint the day was gonna
get to the story the setup was gonna be
there and then I would go into this
great story and then I realized in there
Dave I'm like why did I do a
pre-interview cuz Dave would just go
rogue with you I remember he said um why
aren't there two footballs why don't
they just play two footballs and I go I
I have no idea
like if it wasn't anything we discussed
and then he kept bringing it up he goes
you know like then like two minutes
later yeah I know why don't we have two
footballs you know when the game about
two footballs do you remember when what
was it was it the 20,000th Sports Center
when they decided to actually use all of
us for publicity purposes for one of the
first times ever and divvied up late
night show appearances amongst the
sports center anchors and I think you
went on Dave if I'm not mistaken mm-hmm
I drew the assignment of going on The
Daily Show with Jon Stewart and he this
was before Jon started cursing with
regularity on the show I mean we're
getting a long time ago so I remember
going through the pre-interview he could
not have been nicer and greater to come
backstage and just chitchat and just
shoot the you know a lot about sport
then we get out there the first thing he
says to me is 20,000 sports centers man
that's a whole bunch of BS and use the
actual word just snap that 12/6
curveball
I did not know how to answer that I just
did not a whole crowd like Ward would
laughter definitely wasn't expecting
that one but you have to take those
sorts of instances like I guess they
think you can handle it so I get my way
through it and I don't I don't think I
did very well at it but that was a blast
well I the last time I was on Letterman
I did not wait for him I was gone I was
taking the initiative and I was I was
gonna ask him rogue
yes I I did because I'm like I'm not
gonna wait for him I'm going right at
him and I just I didn't care I was like
you know what I'm gonna ask him some
questions and you know however it falls
out great but I it was I was able to
control it a whole lot more and the fact
that Dave had me on those last couple of
months that he was on the air was you
know very nice but I you know I'd always
come away I go god that was painful and
then his people would say man Dave loves
you I'm like I'd hate to think of he
didn't love me if I feel he thought I
was drunk when I picked the Giants over
the Patriots you know he's like are you
drunk and I'm feeling no and then when I
said Peyton is not staying with the
Colts he kept saying no he's staying
with the Colts I know I said he's not
staying with the Colts Dave yes yes
rolling Dan I had the show description
from The Daily Show with Jon Stewart
where Rich Eisen was a guest I August up
rich and he had on Rob Corddry he had on
something else he said and he accuses
sportscaster of Rich Eisen and sports of
being a fraud but he started really was
Chin Music right from the start and and
a 12-6 curveball to knee the knee
buckling I love that that one off I love
that yeah that's it Pauley that was it
mm - man she's 16 years ago now and so
but it's tough to crack the Letterman
Netflix lineup did you see who he's got
on his new Netflix show right he goes
out of the gate with Obama yeah I know
who else Lee and oh he's got Clooney you
know I mean he went that's Dave top
shelf
yeah I'm not holding out hope I don't
know Joe
not I made my 20 I made my 20,000th
point as a broadcaster yesterday and
nobody noticed and so I don't know what
I'm gonna keep plugging away rich you
got a plot it's not points I keep
telling you he's a Rich Eisen NFL
Network it'll be busy this weekend with
all the NFL coverage and his show on
DirecTV the audience that we're coming
up in about 40 minutes from now rich
good luck this weekend thank you buddy
that's rich ice for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]